birthday coming up
Earth Day yes it is know what people
might not know is if you ask people if
you just ask around
what started Earth Day and you'll get 20
different answers disable the time came
where we just had to think about Earth
and we have to that you'll get a bunch
of different answers so so in retrospect
it's obvious to everyone that it should
have happened right but I don't know
anyone who is fully analyzed the sort of
the meta phenomenon going on at the time
that created the landscape on which this
could have happened at all this year
they're talking about 50 years of Earth
Day so 50 years that's right that's
right so if you want to ask but when did
people start being concerned about the
environment many people will take you
back to 1962 the publication of Rachel
Carson's Silent Spring which was a sort
of a warning to us all in particular
about the use of pesticides on our crops
and what effect that could have in the
ecosphere and on our own health okay I
just gotta stop you right now
well sure how do you know this crap man
seriously yes oh my god I'm an academic
we know stuff that's not only currency
1962 Silent Spring I mean like I had to
write this down because that's it's I
mean Wow
don't you say how come you don't know it
actually very good question alright so
Rachel Carson yeah I actually went to
number one on the New York Times
bestseller for a couple months I think
and so so there were certain seeds
planted there but you have to ask did
those gain taproot did they did they
sprout but what begins to happen in the
mid decade 1965 66 67 we have our
buildup in Vietnam okay
so the Cold War takes on a whole other
patina with a hot war in Southeast Asia
servicemen begin dying and so the pop
culture concerns were not so much about
the environment they were about war so
the attention of the hippie movement
which is so much of what the cultural
iconography of the 1960s captured was
not about the environment that would
happen later hmm
so when did it happen what was the 1966
no 67 No so what happens 1968 comes
around December the first time we leave
Earth for another destination the Apollo
program kicks into high gear and what
happens Apollo 8 leaves earth goes to
the moon didn't land but it goes to the
moon orbits the moon a dozen times one
of those times earth rises above the
lunar landscape and they capture that
photo perhaps the most famous photo ever
taken of anything and it's called
Earthrise and we stood there December
1968 the bloodiest year of the Vietnam
War 1968 we lost more servicemen that
year than any other not only that we
also lost Martin Luther King
we lost Bobby Kennedy the bloodiest year
of the decade December we present we we
scientists engineers cosmic folk present
the world with an image of Earth's
without color-coded countries identified
it was earth as only nature would have
you view it with oceans and land and
clouds that changed us because there we
were alone together in space in the dark
vacuum of space spaceship earth and so
what would happen the whole earth
catalogue
which came out in 1968 they took that
photo and that became their icon that
was that became their cover the Whole
Earth Catalog because we're thinking
about the whole earth now not
internationally because that still
references nations doesn't it we're
talking about a place that has no
borders and what happens 1969 we walk on
the moon for the first time and you know
what happened we went to the moon to
explore the moon and we'd look back and
discovered earth for the first time what
happens in 1970 Earth Day is found in
all of a sudden people are thinking
about Earth's that day it's not called
international day it's not called United
Nations day no forget Nations forget
country it is Earth - what else happens
in 1970 the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration gets founded
before then no one had really linked
together the study of the atmosphere to
the study of the oceans and the Earth's
this was a new concept whose the air and
then there's earth no they're
interconnected climactically NOAA no.8
one of the great names of any
organization of the great acronyms
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
omission 1970 no else happened in 1970
while we are going to the moon the
Environmental Protection Agency is
founded in 1970 1971 what happens
there's a European agency that that's
founded whole Doctors Without Borders
you know they might have happened anyway
but what they've call themselves Without
Borders
where did that concept even arrive in
the absence of an image of Earth that
shows no borders where does that even
come to you and what happens DDT gets
ban 1972 we are still going to the moon
what else oh the clean the Clean Water
Act was in 1972 and leaded gas was bad
1973 and all of lead from the
environment was taken out
all of that happened we stopped going to
the moon in 1972 and it's some spillage
of that mood of what it was to go to the
moon I'll give it to 1973 from 1968 to
73 we were going to the moon looking
back at Earth that's when all of this
happened and Earth Day first in the
United States and then internationally
ask any of those people why they're
doing it civil recourse we have to honor
Earth Mother Earth why did she do that
in 1960 why does he do that in 1950 yhe
way until 1980 why don't you do that in
1962 65 55 why did you do it in 1900 not
you did that while we were going to the
moon and you can do something called an
Engram and look at the frequency with
which certain you words are used and all
printed matter in any given language in
the world you look up words like
environment okay there was a little bit
of blip on it back when Teddy Roosevelt
wanted to preserve the national parks
and then it sort of trickles along
1968-69 the usage goes up by a factor of
all these conservation goes up by a
factor of 10 all these words that we now
associate with the green movement all of
that achieved major currency during the
time we were going to the moon
I simply share with you the observation
that those who say why are we going to
the moon when we're going to space when
we have problems on earth I submit to
you that a perspective descended upon us
that forever changed us and that
perspective of preserving Earth is
priceless
wow man I mean how many jokes for that
dance
I'm the God that was uh I have to say
that that's very profound and what
struck me when you were talking is why
why do we go to space when there's
problems on earth you wouldn't even know
you want earth unless we went to space
there you go you wouldn't know earths
roll earth you wouldn't know how earth
plugged in to the bigger night of
planets and solar system and and later
on the galaxy yeah just playing that the
space program was not only about tang it
was it was just I don't think we weren't
there knowing we would we not rien
ething well how that we would kick in an
understanding of earth and how precious
it is as a life-sustaining planet that I
don't think that was the intent but it
was definitely a consequence and you
remember the most famous commercial of
them all public service announcement
with the Native American tearing up when
people threw garbage at his feet as he
stood along the highway do do you
remember this commercial yeah a lot of
course yeah I mean I mean I would cry
too if people were throwing garbage at
me like feet okay holding it beside the
fact that the guy who played the Native
American is Italian yeah Oh anybody that
he had all these Native American roles
and movies and stuff
hold it holy net aside when was that
commercial do you know I do not know 71
Wow he wasn't 1965 it could have been we
weren't throwing garbage out of the
window anymore in 1970 than we were in
1965 but suddenly we had an aware by the
way there were other natural disasters
pollution visit there was the the the
Love Canal pollution where a chemical
pollution with chemical plants they're
all so it's not like we didn't know
about pollution it's not like we hadn't
thought about pollution it was the
global synthesis of our concern for the
planet without regard to the border is
represented by politics and as Carl
Sagan famously said
air molecules don't carry passports to
move among countries and I can extend
that to water molecules as well you pull
it to water here it spreads around the
world you pull with the air here it
shows up elsewhere okay so all of this
we are in this together and something
during the corona pandemic I think has
driven home certainly for some it may
take a little effort for others is to
recognize that there are many challenges
we face not only as humans but as
civilization that requires a global
cooperative effort to solve I'm in this
country and you're in that country I'll
do my thing you don't do your thing I'll
do my thing excuse me we are all humans
and we are dependent on an ecosystem on
an eco sphere that sustains us so to run
around and say I'm gonna do this whether
or not you do that that is not the
behavior of a species that will become
better Shepherd of its future so that
our descendants can be proud of who we
are in the world we have bequeathed them
rather than embarrassed by what we have
become by the world that we have just
handed them I'm gonna take what Neil
said second for 200 Alex yeah I got a
feeling that the second the latter is is
more likely than the former yeah I want
that like we so it takes another we need
enough you know what it is
we got equally we need another just
another cosmic perspective yes and upon
us in another kind of way each of these
are I think dare I say that they're
their steps in cultural evolution where
the whole world is thinking differently
about something that we either never
thought about before or thought it was
one way rather than another way when in
fact it's a third way that we should be
paying attention to so for me Earth Day
is a triumph of what the space program
has gifted civilization world over
that's a beautiful thing man
that is gorgeous I think what we need is
everybody to take a trip in the Tesla
into outer space we're probably running
out of time but let me let me just share
with you if you speak with the
moonwalkers there aren't many of them
left I've had the privilege of being
friends with most of them including Neil
Michael Jackson Chuck I'm glad you could
slip a joke in the sense ten minutes and
that was a good one that was a good one
you at you you know the mob but go ahead
here's the point they walked on the moon
it's American taxpayers who put them
there it's American engineers who
figured out how to get them there it's
so we can praise the moon walkers
themselves but basically population at
the time 200 million people got them
there so in a sense we all walked on the
moon but watch what happens they travel
internationally and to a person they
would recount this same story foreign
nationals will walk up to them and say
we did it we walked on the moon Wow they
did say you did it
they didn't say Americans did it mm-hmm
they said we did it we finally did it
and that's stuck with them it was in a
profound way because especially though
we planted an American flag the plaque
that was left on the moon was an image
of the earth and it says we come in
peace for all mankind
okay that's what that plaque said nobody
who put flags on mountaintops or
conquered countries or Columbus put in
Spanish flags and cut it did he say we
come in peace for all mankind
no we come for Spain to claim land all
right we come for Germany to take over
we comfort everybody is talking about
this we went to the moon in peace for
all mankind and that message went around
the world well well they better be glad
that I mean everyone is glad that I'm
not
an astronaut two things no people would
have been like we did it and I'd have
been like what you mean we and two
instead of we come a peace for all
mankind
it would have been Chuck was here okay
so Chuck I really glad we'd never made
you a exactly we got to close it out
there all right
those Startalk Earth Day edition in our
little explainer video Chuck always good
to have you on me always a pleasure man
all right I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always
[Music]